Jeff Bezos the founder of Amazon is
worth about a hundred and fifty billion
dollars that's enough to make him the
richest man in the world by far and
possibly the richest human being in all
of human history it's certainly enough
to pay his employees well but he doesn't
a huge number of Amazon workers are so
poorly paid they qualify for federal
welfare benefits according to data from
the non profit group new food economy
nearly 1 in 3 Amazon employees in
Arizona for example was on food stamps
last year Jeff Bezos isn't paying his
workers enough to eat so you made up the
difference with your tax dollars next
time you see Jeff Bezos make certain
distinct what about the Walton family
they founded Walmart collectively
they're worth about a hundred and
seventy-five billion dollars that's more
than the entire gross domestic product
of Qatar the oil-rich Gulf state the
Waltons could certainly afford to be
generous with their workers instead they
count on you to take up the slack in
2013
taxpayers sent more than 6 billion
dollars to Walmart's employees for food
stamps Medicaid and housing assistance
and if you think that's remarkable meet
Travis kalanick he's the youthful
founder of uber his personal fortune is
close to five billion dollars his
drivers
by contrast often make less than minimum
wage one recent study found that many
Luber drivers lose money working for the
company that's not a sustainable
business model the only reason it
continues is because of your generosity
because you're paying the welfare
benefits for ubers impoverished drivers
child billionaires like Travis get to
keep buying bigger houses and more
airplanes he's someone else who owns you
would think you know if you can think of
a less fair system than this send us an
email we'd love to hear about it this
system is indefensible and yet almost
nobody ever complains about it how come
well conservatives like us support the
free market and for good reason the free
market works but there's nothing free
about this market a lot of these
companies operate as monopolies they
hate markets they use government
regulation to crush competition there's
nothing conservative about that just as
there's nothing conservative
most being corporations just the
opposite they're the backbone of the
left pick a left-wing cause that you
think is hurting the country check the
donor list and you'll find the name of
some corporation often many corporations
corporate America enables the
progressive lunacy you see every night
on this show they are funding the
revolution now in progress
that's exactly why liberals say nothing
as oligarchs amassed billions by soaking
our middle class because they've been
paid off for example you probably assume
the people who founded Walmart were
conservative most of their customers
certainly are yet the bulk of the Walton
family backed Hillary Clinton in the
last election they gave the Democratic
Party more than 700 thousand dollars
during the 2016 cycle almost every
billionaire in Silicon Valley did the
same in return for that they got
immunity from criticism and they got to
keep forcing you to pay their employees
it was a good deal for them there is one
person in Washington who was offended by
this arrangement and we're sorry to say
he's wrong on pretty much everything
else but this is a weird moment in
American politics so you take allies
where you can find them Bernie Sanders
of all people is trying to get your
money back from Jeff Bezos this is
especially amazing since Bezos is unburn
East Side on most things
they're both left-wing activists but on
this question Bernie is right he's
planning legislation that would force
big corporations to return the
taxpayer-funded welfare benefits you
have paid to their workers it's not a
perfect solution and it's unlikely to
pass no matter what they may say in
public liberals in Congress would never
support something like that their
loyalty is not to you it's to uber and
Jeff Bezos and the rest but at the very
least legislation like this might awaken
a sleepy population to the new reality
of activist corporate America and that's
a good thing America has changed
enormous ly in the last 20 years a lot
of people you thought were your allies
are in fact working against your
interests they have contempt for you and
your family your customs and your faith
included in this group I'm sorry to say
there are a lot of big corporations they
have no use for you or the country you
up and stand in their way and they'll
crush you you're watching it all around
us all the time
it's shocking so shocking that I
recently wrote a book about it
it's called ship of fools in and
explained what happened who did it and
why the book is out in a month the first
week of October but you can pre-order a
copy now and I hope you will